hi good afternoon to all thank you
for coming so many to this
talk introd action to google cloud
machine learning
what is the goal of this session
first try to tell you how
in google
we exploit the benefits of machine
learning then what are in our opinion the
main critical issues  for the business
of your organization how
we try to solve the
main problems of marcello ning and what is the
technology we use most
internally and later we will see
how google can provide tools
that can help you to adopt
machine learning in your systems t we will
continue with the story  of how some
organizations worldwide are
already benefiting from machine
learning and then I will suggest I will
allow you to suggest
steps that anyone can follow
as soon as you go home how
machine learning is used in google
then I don't know if you remember  that 34 years
ago sundar pic  you have our ceo had
said that we were moving in a
mobile first world and actually in
the searches on google search arrived from
mobile were more than those
that came from the web so sundar
was right so I tend to trust a
lot at the moment  which says that we
are moving in a world but the link
first precisely because there are
enormous enormous opportunities that we can
go to exploit as we are machine
learning to google then first of all the
search engine
you know that when you search for a keyword on
google there are many  many criteria that
are used to decide which
result to bring higher than others
in the screen that you certainly know
well rank brain is a deep neural network
that is used together with other
tools to achieve this
result or to provide you
with relevant search results with respect to
keywords and  it is the third that gives a
positive contribution that is among all the
alg  orithms that there are to define which
result is more
relevant than your keyboard
rank brain is the third also it is the one
that in the last two years has brought
the largest imprudent one that has
contributed most to the improvement
of the google search algorithm therefore
a first example of a system that uses a
lot of machine learning google
photos probably many of you
use it in private life able
to identify faces within
images and is able to make you
search such as photos
of my son at the sea or  anything else
here too clearly a lot of machine
learning not to mention the smart
replay that we have recently released
both on inbox and on gmail which based on
how you usually reply to
emails is able to offer you an answer
to give to an email  as soon as it arrived I
personally use it very often and it
allows me to save time with
google translate by installing the app on
your smartphone
you are able to do this or
point the camera at something
that is written in a language you do not
understand and have the same image
but with the translation installed
google translate
you can do it immediately
also in spreadsheet our system
to manage sheets  of calculation
if you have a spreadsheet
that contains a lot of data and maybe you don't know
where to start to generate a
graph you have at the bottom right a
button called explore that generates
graphs automatically, saving you a
lot of time because it is not
a  very simple operation
creating graphs more often than not and
above all perhaps allowing you to
discover insights that
you had not even noticed in the spreadsheet
itself
also in March 2016
you probably heard of
this great news that a
computer has managed to beat a
human being  to the go game which is the most
popular game in there  so it is one of the
most popular games in the world on 5 games the
computer was able to win
four was something that in 2015
seemed absolutely impossible
just as in 96 it seemed impossible
that a computer could have beaten
a human being at chess and yet the
technology goes on
the algorithms are more and more advanced
the hardware allows to carry out the
computations in an increasingly
performing and efficient way and here it is
an extremely sophisticated machine learning algorithm
on an
extremely performing hardware could
be the basis of this extraordinary
victory  which has been considered a
milestone are elected both in the world
of artificial intelligence obviously
also in our data centers
we use machine learning a lot
this is an image of the hamina data center
in finland where I had
the honor of working for about a  month
each google data center consists
of more than one building from  more than one
building essentially inside each building
there are more floors and each floor can
have up to 100 150 corridors
here you can see about twenty corridors
each corridor has a double row of
servers where
the chassis that contains the servers is
about three high  meters then imagine how much
energy it takes to give life to
all the servers
this is another image a little
closer just to give an idea
well there is a coefficient a
standard unit of measurement that defines how
efficient the use of the  energy
from a machine in our case
from a data center is called more and
that is the ratio between how much a server
should consume at the energy level
in the ideal world and how much it
actually consumes because we know that there are
operations such as dehumidification and
cooling  and anything else now
since we tried to manage
the energy in our data centers to a
machine learning algorithm you see
how there has been an i  m positive impact
quite significant therefore since
you see machine learning control
on our data centers they have immediately
become more efficient than without
the machine learning algorithm that
precisely manages the energy that
feeds it as soon as the all control is deactivated
as soon as power is removed.
to the machine learning algorithm here is
that the servers start to consume
more then another example of how in
google machine learning is
massively used some queries
from the future so some challenges and
some questions that in google we have been
asking ourselves for a
while.  these retinal images
show symptoms of diabetes
or the one I like the most on the
right find
me all the documents in this
database that are related to the topic
of rennes forsman learning make a
summary it is really in german
so I put in a lot of
problems still  unsolved
artificial intelligence machine as well as
watch this video and it describes in
a specific language there are many queries
that I like to say come from the future
but a few years ago it seemed
impossible to beat a human at the
alpha go game so why not set yourself
extremely challenging challenges that
seem impossible but who knows what a
tomorrow we will really not be able to
answer even this type of
questions
but what are
the main challenges
in the business world when we talk
about machine learning
first of all we have to try to manage
heterogeneous data sources between them is
already here is not much  simple to go and
merge the data source coming
from different systems
then prepare the data it is not easy to
take data from multiple sources and
prepare them in such a way that they can
be processed efficiently
build analytical models or
build models that can be
integrated into  existing business processes
or still being in  able
in a very reasonable time to create
machine learning models that
give benefits and to be able in an
equally short time to explore them in
our production systems because
many times we have some
very beautiful ideas but a lot of time passes
before seeing them in practice the challenge
clearly it is to make sure that
from the excellent idea to the diploma in
production of the excellent
and it is very little time passes in
particular based on our
experience on machine
learning projects with many companies in the world
we note that every vertical essentially
has the  therefore, for example,
in the manufacturing world predictive maintenance is its good point
because waiting for a
machine to break down to intervene
maybe we can identify
symptoms that allow us to intervene
earlier at a lower cost without creating
downtime in the production chain
or in the world of retail  the whole
theme of cross channel marketing or
in the world of health care proactive art
management
we know that prevention is
better than cure is not the same for a
health care to treat a patient long
before very serious symptoms
of a disease appear rather than after the
costs and probabilities of bringing the
treatment  if they are successful they
are decidedly different or in the
world of hospitality travel make
sure that feedback is good and
where it is not good manage it
promptly in the world of financial
services be able to classify
different users into very
risk-prone to risk-unwilling  maybe
to make a loan proposal or a
financial product in the most
relevant way in the energy field as
we said before try to
use energy as
efficiently as possible since it is a
precious and limited resource how
can we try to support them in  all of
these challenges
first and foremost as the
primary machine learning technology
we use  in google it is that of money to the
network but first let me say that
clearly a matching system
always part of the data with an algorithm and then
somehow you have to turn on a
light bulb that thanks to machine learning
allows me to discover something
interesting in the data itself
all this is typically done thanks to
neural networks let me tell you in
an extremely simple way a series
of layers many layers one after the other
each in fact in an extremely
fast and performing way effect a
piece of computation in such a way
that in correspondence
an input  and as a sign I am able to
give an output so for example in
correspondence with an image of a
certain animal or a certain object to say
that in that photo there is a
dog a cat whatever else how do
these systems learn to recognize
something in an extremely
simple way you have to give it and many
examples of that so is a cat what is
a dog what is  a car
imagine a thousand images of a cat a
thousand images of a dog, etc. in
such a way that the system slowly, in the
face of various training laps
of various of various executions
of the training algorithm that allows you
to learn, is able to understand  from the
examples that when one day we give him
an image of a cat without telling him that it
is a cat he is able to say
yes I have seen a thousand in the past they are
all very similar so in all
probability 90 95 percent at least I
tell you that in  this image for which he did
not tell me what is inside there is a cat
this is also known as supervising
machine learning and is a technology
used in an extremely widespread way
in many google products
now machine learning in production
means this
that is to train a
model then we take a thousand photos of
the cat a thousand photos of the dog or whatever
you want
I have to have many examples to give
to my system  ema so that he is able
to learn and then test the model
until an accuracy of 80 85
percent reaches 95 98 percent in
such a way as to be considered
substantially reliable the player
in the production environment and then
continuously update it because
we know  well then things
always change over time and I can't think of
putting there a machine
learning model that will never require
changes again so the player also means
being able to
quickly and easily update it and make sure that
the  card the accuracy of your
answers is always greater is always
closer to 100 percent
how can google help with the
google cloud tools with
the google cross platform
tools first of all ok the
cloud platform tools are many we have
reached about 67  blue hexagons for each
category we say of service of
instrument that serves in
any application our session
sent  ire inside they are silent on machine
learning so we focus on only the
last column of products
and zooming in we see that
first of all there is tensor flow what is
senso flow is a framework written in
open source python that can be
used by anyone  it is something
decidedly aligned with
google's corporate culture to vision the
google mission which plans to create
technology and then share it therefore
tensor flow is a tool that has been
developed in google contains all the
google know-how behind a tide
of products  of google including the
ones I showed you before and is at your
disposal to create a
machine learning model that is adequate for
your needs
but who at least once tried it
knows that creating a model that works
well is a process that requires
a very long time requires many
attempts requires the experimentation of
dozens if not hundreds of
different models where in each m  odel I change
some parameters to try to understand
then in practice which one
behaves better it is not easy to do this
in a short time it can take months
and here we have released
on the market cloud machine learning which is
a tool that allows you to bring
the training  of new machine
learning models for weeks if not months to hours
and this means that what that
very painful phase in which I have a good idea
but I see it in production perhaps in a
few months is something
decidedly shortened of decidedly
reduced or a  nice idea
I have to be able in a two
weeks to see if it really works
and to purify it in production calm sheen
lenin helps you exactly
this because behind cloud machine
learning there is a new processor that
was designed created and produced by
google called  tensor flo
processing unit so ti more than it is
fast 40 50 times faster than the gpu
we know well that the cpu are not much
suitable for carrying out
machine learning operations typically then
slowly we have moved to the gpu
that are ten hundred times more for
more performing than a cpu in
terms of machine learning read more read
more excuses introduce another
disruption then a 40  50 lost
performance and you can use them inside cloud
machine and therefore tensor flow anyone
can also install it on their laptop
but we strongly recommend that you
try machine learning because precisely
the performance you access is
truly amazing and will leave you
speechless.  the other part for those who do not want to create
machine learning models from scratch,
using however starting from
all the google know-how through
tensor flow but those wishing to
use ready-made models can do it
through machine learning and ip ice therefore
time to write  the code that
calls an ep and you are able to
immediately add
i  ntelligence to your applications
what are these pious this morning
because it was the keynote we have seen the
video intelligence and pil or given a
video I am able to describe what
happens in all the frames of the video
so an operation that I should do
by hand and that  it would take me a long
time it is done automatically in fact
in a second so the video
intelligences pious and are able in
fact automatically to describe
a video and tell you what happens in each
frame of the video is the same technology
that is used by google  and youtube
made available to you through an
e pious and which is very simple to
integrate or the pious vision is given
an image they are able to identify
faces and if the person has a
happy
angry face surprised what else they are
able to tell you  what is
in the image i can extract
text from images i can
extract a logo i can tell you
if there is in the image  it is a content that is not
suitable for a child or a
sensitive audience and they are able to
do a whole series of operations that
if you were to write
the machine learning algorithm at home and do
all these things it would take a
long time
to do so invoked  an ep ai you have an
answer jason that tells you
everything he sees in the image for
example on the left two friends
running on the beach content safe on the
right a soldier who shoots
unsafe content so do what you want with
the image but at least know  that there is
content that could shock
someone or this girl you see
surprise very likely is a surprised face
in fact in this other face
obviously anger so in all
probability the epia and they say that
first of all there is a face and a face
that  this simply joyful face is also angry
so joy very
likely here we think for example
in the retail sector if we had
images of people  looking at my
shop window two girls looking at a pair
of shoes
two faces are identified and both are marked
as very joyful and it could not be
otherwise
and here we obviously have someone like me who
is perhaps looking at the last smartphone
in the shop and the face  here too it
can only be joy very likely but not
only this is a jeans so with a
99.9% safety
we are faced with a jeans or here
we are faced with a 99% safety t shirt
here at 98% I am sure  that there is a
queue so you see the system recognizes
crowd crowd with a 98 percent safety
here very simply we identify
a logo so know that you are going to
publish an innkeeper to use
an image that has a logo do what
you want but know that there is  it's a logo then it
's up to you to decide if you want to do it no but in the
meantime I warn you or this is a
hard disk object recognition theme
and I could go on for a
long time  imo because the pious visions and
since they were released have already
noticed about a billion and a half of
images there are also natural
languages and pii in correspondence with a phras
that maybe you have fished from a post
n facebook from a tweet from an email
to  customer service what you
want syntactic analysis
interesting but not too
interesting entity recognition of what
we are talking about in the sentence of
what we are talking about a film of a city of
a book here starts to be
interesting but in my opinion the best
of the  nature lingua gpi is linked to
sentiment analysis i.e. you
administer a sentence a sentence
coach language pia and they are
able to tell you if the mood if the person
who wrote that sentence is happy
or not we
imagine the e-mails and towards the
customer service  or posts on twitter and
on your twitter account or on
your facebook page the next event is
very interesting positive sentiment ho
evi  marked me in green but imagine you
have a value ranging from minus 1 to plus
one is clearly there are three brackets
green yellow red I have been to this
customer in this shop
the service has turned out to be very good
green positive sentiment I
recommend everyone to participate  at the next
next year obviously I know that
you will do it green very positive feelings
in that company using that product
I felt good but not too yellow
so it is not a critical statement
but perhaps it should be managed at least you
have to ask yourself questions
or quality of service of the  media
is not saying bad but not
very good I will not go to
that restaurant again put what you
want
the wait was really too much
negative sentiment here probably
you have to intervene before maybe he
writes this on facebook before
maybe he shares it in a way  very
extensis or I just phoned
that customer service and the operator
wasn't genti  the negative feeling
this is the potential of nature and
language pia is a call that
allows you to bring
all the intelligence that google has already been using
internally for years in your
it systems in an extremely extremely
simple and fast way
pious species also exist and therefore
given an audio sample given a file
containing I don't know the recording of
a phone call or the recording of
any other conversation you have as
a return value the transcription of
what is said when you have for
example at home thousands and thousands of
audio files from which you want  extract the
text you can do the processing instead
offline asynchronous excuse of the technicality
but it is to say that it launches the day the
job on the cloud platform slowly
you have back the transcription of a
long series of files that maybe were there
and you didn't have to how to use them you can
do  a request to the pious and passing
the audio recording and
immediately having the tr  registration
or you can use the more ai species
also to enable voice control scenarios of the
application
because these pia and also work in
streaming so as
the user of your app for example
speaks to the application you have back on
the server side that  that the user is
saying in real time
you can decide to trigger
actions or do something
so they work both in beige mode and
in real time
mod we also have the traslation and pia and
probably many of you use google
translate anyway from 103 languages to other
103 languages which are the same but t
ere are all the various combinations so yo
can translate in practice from any l
nguage to any language and they are t
e state of the art as regar
s the text translation so to co
clude this section on the googl
tools that exist for the
jaws that how can
the situation we have seen over the
years in many a can help you on the left  companies without the
tools that I told you in
the right column after starting
to use the google tools so
in essence I can save a
lot of time that I take away from activities
I
have not connected to my core business that are not
particularly rewarding even for
the developer himself and  to the logo 100
percent of the energy of my team of
developers or of data santis
anything else on what really counts,
i.e. on going to create an algorithm
that really adds value to my
business that allows me to take the next
step in  my product in my service or
anything else in terms of quality
perceived by the customer himself
precisely quality perceived by the customer
himself
we see how some customers some
companies that already use these services that
I have told you are reaping
benefits for example if it is the
main online supermarket  of
known uk and uk for the quality of the service
as they do the prioritization of the
emails sent to  Customer service through
natural language processing therefore an
email like this where the customer
is very happy obviously does
not necessarily have to be handled
immediately an email in which the
customer says I have not received a
delivery I am very disappointed with the service
or an email where there is  written do not
give me the shopping between 18 and 20
we agreed so but I am not at
home so we postpone the delivery must be
managed immediately to prevent the warehouse,
for example,
the frozen foods are pulled out at an
unexpected time that is not  plus the correct one
as you can see there is also always the feedback button
because as mentioned before the system
must always be able to
continuously learn from the human being
imagine you are the children
of a
[ __ ] excuse me the term may seem
something positive ah how nice  her
mother is a very good lady but
we know well that she has a
decidedly negative connotation so here it is
necessary  he would write the feedback no it
is not green the red and after three four
five times we are told
wrong he must be able to
learn and mark as red in the future
this airbus statement
we have already mentioned this morning during
the keynote he had the problem of having to
distinguish the snow
that is on the ground on the
earth essentially from the snow clouds to
airbus cannot care less about the
clouds instead yes one thing is to have
operators who manage the
images that come from the satellite
very often very high resolution
imagined for a  very small geographical area
even how many images there can
be and now they have a
machine learning algorithm that thanks to cloud and
mail they were able to instruct
in a very very short time and
now have an accuracy well
above 90 percent  and year in
production this system which, as
you can see at the top right, is able to
distinguish the n  snow
so a long operation with
a not very high accuracy is
made extremely fast with
a higher accuracy outlet is
a Japanese company in fact it is a
website that allows on the one hand to
upload the photo of the photo
of the car that I want to sell
from the other obviously looking for
second-hand cars
now also here one thing is to have
the operator look at all the images
the tags you see in front behind
right side left side dashboard and
whatever else is an account to have  a
machine learning algorithm that is
able to recognize everything
automatically so if you do it went to
create an offer on an outlet this offer
will go to the market before other
sites and you maximize the probability that
someone who wants to buy that car
actually go and buy it from
your site rather than from the site of
others because from others who do not use
machine learning the offer will come out three
four five thu  rni later
and you have an advantage so outlet
is able to take advantage
of this advantage of the series I like to win
easy
spotify thanks to our tools it is
able to suggest playlists which is one
of the core features of
spotify for those who use it at a time  which
is no more than 12 days but in a time
that can even be minutes
so how long does it take me to react to
new things I discover about the user of the
new characteristics of the user
when I react to user actions
that denote
the  'interest in something I have to
react almost instantaneously they cannot
react in two days because I
have to wait for the process to start butch
etc. they were able to do it
too thanks ab query which just
was discovered by one of their
engineers caused this very tweet  sympathetic
where he says that of those in essence it is the
most beautiful thing that has happened to him in
life I do not know what he does in his
private life but eq  his is what he
wrote then everyone can think what
he wants
sure is that being able to pass from days to
minutes in any organization
creates a very pleasant situation
so google tools help
in this because we have the same
scalability we provide you with
the  same scalability that we use
for our services
beautiful I think everything we
have told us so far but I would like to
allow myself even in these last
minutes to share with you some phases
that we see as common in every
machine learning process because I do not want
to over-sell by saying that  machine
learning has the magic wand that
solves all problems
there is a need to start a path a
job that maybe will bring results
not necessarily tomorrow but it will take
a minimum of time because there are
steps that must be followed first of all you
need quality of the data  i always allow myself
to suggest to the clients i
work with rac  collect data even if
you do not really know what we are going to
do but first of all we collect data
and this data must be of
quality quality means that maybe in a
file you have latitude in a column in
a longitude column in another
source  data you have a single column
position with latitude longitude
here we already have a problem the data
must be made homogeneous and then google has
released a tool called data
prep which is able through a
machine learning algorithm to identify which
syntactically different data sources
denote the same concept capable of
generating a pipe line that normalizes
different data sources to you
once I am able to
collect the data once this
data is of quality can evolve
to the next stage where I
need to describe the data describe
the data means that when I have large
databases I can't wait
overnight to get the result of a
qu  ery I can't really wait to
go into the other room to ask a
person who writes me here I want to
have results immediately
and then here is the tool that google
proposes for this phase eb query that
allows you to analyze an
endless amount of data the second instead of  in
hours so for example here on the
very nice description the story of ups
that in new york has discovered that for
their vans it is much better to make three
right turns rather than one
left you save petrol
the packages arrive first at the customers
and there are fewer accidents because
we know well that turning to the left
is never easy
so better to make three turns to the right
they did not know a priori that they would have
achieved this result, however,
collecting data and being able to
describe them meant that they later
discovered this  pretty cool thing
once i am able to
describe the data here i can really
start  think about the classification
of data let's think for example how important it is
in industry 4.0 to be
able to identify those patterns that
make me understand immediately why a
machine broke
so a machine is sending so many signals
to my system I am collecting data
from the machines this is  the first thing
I would do in terms of industry 4.0 then a
machine breaks breaks today
breaks tomorrow etc. I accumulate data and I
am able to identify a pattern
in such a way that as soon as a
machine breaks down I don't necessarily have to send
an expert the day
after to understand what happened
the maxillans algorithm immediately prevent me
where to intervene and I
can carry out a repair in an
economic way within a few minutes
then or less down time from the
production chain or let's imagine in
healthcare having a flood of
retinal images and  then having to wait for
an expert look at all the images to
understand which ones are that  le that reveal the
symptoms of diabetic retinopathy
here is a vessel damage algorithm can
do it immediately so here too
big improvement in being
able to classify data but returning
to the topic you wear 4.0 because waiting for
a machine to break can evolve
towards the next phase  that of
prediction or if a
scrap machine gives 10 symptoms
when I see 78 of them I can say with
sufficient certainty that
that machine will probably break in a while
and then I can even intervene
first this is true in the indus
4.0 plank but we even think in healthcare
how many  how important it would be
to be able to collect data from
patients or from people who do not
yet have a disease but simply
collect data in order to be able
to predict which symptoms will
show themselves to intervene much sooner for
the good of the patient in an even
cheaper way  the final point of
evolution I call it semantic
or  vvero is the one in which we are able
to consider heterogeneous data sources
in order to discover
something interesting
for example if I combine the accesses to
my ecommerce site to give
very simple examples to the weather forecasts
I could discover that  when it rains or
more accesses because maybe people
will leave the house less then if I have to
decide when to launch an offer on
my ecommerce site
maybe I could launch it when I
expect maximum access or
either a service station or a
restaurant whatever  you want on
a road
I could combine the information related
to traffic forecasts to the staff
thing of the staff or another
very nice example that was
proposed to us last year carry out the
go to recover at
the stars black friday
the posts on  twitter and post on facebook and
see how the signs as sentiment
varies following the launch of offe  rte of
marketing on the offers
of us on new products on the market
that is I launch a new offer
at the leicester black
friday with the natural language pia
I should see an improvement in the
sentiment towards the brand that
launched the offer and so it was then
the offer is withdrawn from the market
after a while and we see that on twitter and
facebook the sentiment
towards my brand is slightly less
positive than there was the offer
so this is another example for which
I am going to combine sources of  heterogeneous data
in order to obtain something
interesting so with this start of mine
to conclude I allow myself to make a
very quick final assumption so
we have seen how in google machine
learning is heavily used for
many of the products you know for
practically all the products you
know  the same technology
behind it is at your disposal
you can use it is called google cloud
platform is at your disposal  available
we have seen how many companies
are already taking
very significant benefits thanks to
machine learning and I also took the
liberty of suggesting steps that
in a short time can lead you to
have benefits even in your context
thank you for your attention good
continuation
[Applause]